in baden-württembergischen Mannheim ist
der fahrlachtunnel seit anderthalb
Jahren gespart der gesamte Verkehr quält
sich jetzt durch die Stadt der grund für
die Sperrung sind gravierende Fehler
beim Brandschutz fast 30 Jahre war der
Tunnel eine potentielle Todesgefahr für
alle Nutzer jahrzehntelang hat niemand
bei der Stadt bemerkt dass das Ding gar
nicht den Vorschriften entspricht es ist
im Prinzip wie kann ich sowas
vernachlässigen gerade wenn man sowas so
Aktionen schon sehe was zu tun und alles
passieren kann ich nicht nachvollziehen
also das ist fast 30 Jahre lang gar
nicht bemerkt worden ist das macht mich
sprachlos da weiß ich auch nicht mehr
weiter das ist einfach eine Katastrophe
für uns Mannheimer weil wir müssen uns
einfach eine andere Strecke suchen
eigentlich fahren täglich rund 60.000
Fahrzeuge durch den Tunnel der 1994
eingeweiht wird schon beim Bau wird bei
der Sicherheit gespart statt zwei
Gebäuden mit Fluchttreppen gibt's nur
eines
Stadt der geplanten 18 Lüfter pro Röhre
werden nur acht eingebaut
2006 gibt es eine Verschärfung der
Vorschriften wegen Brandkatastrophen
müssen alle Tunnel untersucht und
nachgerüstet werden bei der Stadt
Mannheim geschieht das nicht erst vor
anderthalb Jahren fällt das alles auf
seitdem ist der tunneldicht ein
Untersuchungsbericht fällt das
vernichtende Urteil es liegt ein
gesamtorganisatorisches Versagen vor
es braucht er schon irgendwelche
Institutionen die sie mit sowas
auskennen und Architekten Ingenieure und
dann ist eigentlich verwunderlich dass
lange Zeit da niemand darauf aufmerksam
geworden aufmerksam wurde wir haben so
viel Vorschriften und alles und da
passiert sowas in so einem
hochoffizielle Tunnel wo tagtägliche
tausende von Autos und LKWs durchfahren
in Mannheimer Rathaus hat man sich jetzt
das Problems angenommen und saniert den
Straßen Tunnel entsprechend der
Vorschriften die Verantwortlichen für
das Bau Desaster hat man bis heute aber
nicht gefunden schriftlich heißt es nach
unseren bisherigen Erkenntnissen des
aufarbeitungsprozesses gibt es keine
Hinweise auf schuldhaftes Verhalten von
einzelnen Personen
zum Glück gab es in den vergangenen
Jahren keine schweren brandunfälle fragt
man sich
in der Demokratie wie kann das sein wo
man immer denkt da gibt es Gremien die
auch andere kontrollieren das ist nicht
normal also da wurde wahrscheinlich
wieder kaputt gespart und ja darüber
hinweg geguckt und
man kann nur den Kopf schütteln
eigentlich derzeit wird der Tunnel für
2,9 Millionen Euro not ertüchtigt die
Stadt hofft dass er kurz nach Ostern
wieder befahrbar ist danach muss er dann
noch generalsaniert werden